christmas in rome during covid
where goodwill to others means socially
distant events providing presents to the
poor and homeless
as welcome as these gifts may seem what
many people want this winter is the
covid vaccine
and now the first consignments of it
have arrived in rome
ready for distribution on sunday to
people who the pope says should be first
on the list
i pray for all those in charge of
nations companies international
organizations to promote cooperation and
not competition
and look for a solution for everybody
vaccines for everybody
especially for the most vulnerable and
needy ones in every region of the planet
as in many other eu countries the
vaccine will also start being
distributed in germany on sunday
it's a development many hope will
transform the situation
we see the long awaited light at the end
of the tunnel become brighter
we will come closer to the exit from
this crisis step by step
how long the road will be depends on us
if we remain reasonable and patient
then we will gradually be able to do
many things again that we had to do
without for a long time
the strategy many european governments
are adopting is twofold
a return to hard lockdowns and the start
of mass vaccinations
their hope is to reduce the numbers of
new infections and eventually
lower a mortality rate that has been
claiming the lives of
thousands of people every day for some
time
dominic kane al jazeera berlin